pikachu hallo herzlich willkommen sallys
welt das heutige video entstand ziemlich
spontan denn es ist was passiert ja und
zwar vor allem der staat und überall ich
glaube auf der ganzen welt laufen
pokémon herum und jeder verrückt wie
einzufangen
als wahrscheinlichster trend jetzt bei
euch nicht an euch vorbei gegangen
momentan steht jeder an der straße und
sagt so durch die straßen
pokémon bis gestern eigentlich auch
nichts davon
bis dann unser team kam zu spät
weil er am brunnen rang halten musste
vollkommen pokemon eingefangen hatten
und jetzt denkt was redet die zwei tag
genau ist ein spieler für die handys dar
und zwar von go und da kannst du eben
die hat schon eine karte aber das
erschließt eine echte karte also auf uns
rechten straße und läuft man durch die
straße und irgendwo wieder niemand
pokemon angezeigt wenn man dann mit dem
handy einfangen kann
mein erster pokemon saß übrigens hier in
meiner küche auf meine mülleimer und
fallen was aber einer in meinem backofen
genau und werfen soll erst einmal zeit
um diese kleinen tierchen vor paar jahre
lang ist und cooles spiel weil man muss
halt nach draußen gehen viel laufen und
die ganzen pokémon entdecken genau also
uns hat auch eine zuschauerin
geschrieben sich am wochenende 40
kilometer gelaufen und pokémon slogan
genau unterhalb des noch andere
geschrieben dass ihr so jetzt gern mit
dem hund gassi gehen wenn der hund etwas
schwierigen witterung
es hat wenig sinn sein ganz positiven
effekte ganz er leute die jetzt raus und
uns anderen negativen zwischen nicht
vergessen es ist spät und ich finde ein
spiel mit suchtgefahr mit suchtgefahr
absolut ich war gestern starken man halt
dass sie ihre rumgelaufen hast du
wirklich an
wirklich ein reh ins auto holt er muss
aufpassen also wenn man das spiel spielt
finde ich sollte man auf jeden fall weg
von der straße ich glaube ich schnell
verstehen dass man mit dem handy hat auf
die straße weil ich bin gestern auf
unserer terrasse gelaufen genau also
wirklich wieder das spiel spielt oder
wenn eure tipps das spiel auch immer
allerhand ihnen dass es auch gefährlich
sein kann denn es ist wirklich ein sehr
sehr großes suchtpotenzial da hat alles
wie im leben dass ich außer den
verwunderten vor nachteile was sie erst
ganz kurz neben real weiter machst und
dann kam noch jemand die genau diese app
ist kostenlos zum herunterladen müssen
merken auf der welt gibt es nichts was
kostenlos alle daten daten dadurch frei
man weiß wo ihr euch befindet
persönliche zugriffe frei also überlegt
euch zwei mal ob wir diese herunterladen
und rechts mit ihren eltern genau auf
jeden fall ist sehr zweischneidig slice
wir haben damals pochen und geschaut wo
wir noch jünger war einfach im fernsehen
und haben die karten gesammelt oder da
gab es das spiel nicht und du hast deine
jugend erzählen
ich hatte keinen jugend war ich erzähle
was ich heute gemacht habe und zwar
halte mir gedacht jetzt ist verstimmt
dieser trend überall da alle kinder
wollen wieder pokemon und deswegen habe
ich kekse backen mit dem thema pokemon
und habe hier diese kapek aufleger
gemacht auch modelle schokolade also ich
habe jetzt hier die poker bälle und vier
der ich sag mal der bekannteren pokemon
ausgesucht unter anderem cumulus
promille und pikachu pkt sieht aus wie m
naja jedenfalls zeige ich euch wie ich
jetzt hergestellt habe und startet dafür
gleich mein lieblings pokémon ist
übrigens redaktion
ja das ist ein bisschen lockerer typ ist
von darf kein poker bauwerke müssen die
last sichtbar werden
aber wenn du hast
für die muffins habe ich jetzt bereit
meinen grundrezept gerichtet also den
ganz normalen muffin teig mit etwas
vanille extrakt und ansonsten hat keinen
geschmack das o2-netz vanille machen und
jetzt habe ich hier ein paar filmchen
und zwar schon in den farben wie gibt
auch eben die pokémon machen werde ich
habe vier rote zwei liliane die stehen
dann für rosa zwei g2 grün und blau
und jetzt werde ich dementsprechend
immer einen esslöffel voll von dem teig
abstechen und die motionen einfärben
und jetzt nämlich lebensmittel
verpasster und geht die jeweilige farbe
mit dazu und dann noch höre ich das noch
gut um
ich will zeigen die teige auf die
papierversion aufgeteilt
so werden die martin wirtz im vorletzten
backofen bei 160 grad
dienste wie etwa 20 minuten gebacken und
dann satz komplett abkühlen
die muffins habe ja bereits gebacken
habe ich gestern gebacken habe sie
abgedeckt abkühlen lassen und jetzt habe
ich auch ein bisschen was vorbereitet
für die dekoration und zwar habe ich
hier ein paar kreise bereits
ausgestochen auch gestern abend damit
die fest werden und war sind die aus
modelle schokolade modelle schokolade
nämlich ganz gerne weil sie einen seite
natürlich super schmeckt man echte
schokolade mit drin steckt und sie wird
auch relativ fest das heißt etwas besser
als vom band und ich kann sie auch auf
seine krems benutzen
und jetzt habe ich hier die kreise so
gemacht ich habe es hier etwas weiß
und weil gelb die einzige farbe ist bei
der modellierte nicht gibt muss ich
jetzt gelb einfärben mit etwas passend
farbe und das jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen ein kneten
so könnt ihr übrigens auch jede
beliebige farbe mischen und damit die
modelle schokolade jetzt gleich wichtig
wird nämlich diese zwei holzstäbchen die
haben uns drei millimeter dicke und kann
es jetzt mit etwas becker stärker
einfach ausräumen
nämlich dann ausstecher oder zum
beispiel ein glas was ungefähr so groß
wie der bafin und kann jetzt die kreise
ausstechen zur seite legen und die
können dann einfach ein bisschen
antrocknen und zwar wie es dafür zwei
rote und zwei weise kreise und die muss
ich jetzt erstmal halbieren mit dem
poker ball fängt man übrigens alle
pokémon 1
und jetzt führte immer einen roten und
einen weißen zusammen und jetzt nehmt
ihr einen kleineren aus tech ich hab
jetzt hier eine spritztour ihr könnt
aber zum beispiel auch einen deckel
nehmen oder ein dickeres reichen also
alles was ihr zuhause findet und müsste
sie in der mitte noch im kreis
ausstechen und mit dem gleichen aus hier
steche ich jetzt noch einen weißen kreis
aus jetzt lebe ich die teile mit etwas
zucker kleber als mit sap zusammen
und in die mitte kommt noch der kleine
kreis und wenn die quelle dann ein
bisschen an getrocknet sind könnt ihr
die schwarzen linien machen
dafür nehme ich jetzt hier diese fondant
presse und geht dann ein bisschen
schwarzen von dann drei sondern einfach
ein bisschen weicher ist als modelle
schokolade
da kommt jetzt diese teile drauf das ist
so ein langes band was dann entsteht da
gibt's auch mehrere vorsätze und da wird
es geschlossen und kann jetzt raus
gekurbelt werden
streitigkeiten ein bisschen kleber auf
diese methe
und dann kann ich die strenge anlegen
und dann einfach mit dem lebensmittel
farbstiften kreis noch einmal pikachu
jetzt ist bisasam an der reihe das ist
der grüne pokémon und dafür habe sie
zieren bisschen weiß und grün bereits
ausgerollt ist sondern das habe ich
gestern abend gemacht dann trocknet und
so könnt ihr diese dünnen teile dann
auch besser zu schneiden
pikachu jetzt ist quartal an der reihe
dass es die blaue schildkröte
und jetzt ist an der reihe
warum denkt so pastor luft braucht jetzt
noch mal für fünf braucht jetzt noch mal
ein stück christa dem modell ihr
schokolade
die müsst ihr warten und dann sondern
langen strang formen und das sieht dann
aus wie so ein kleines schwein der 20
ich bin relation gelacht so aussieht
nein ich echt riesig
also auch als ein großer strang
das wirbelt dem einfach so warum wusste
was im gesicht hat aber die zuschauer
ich denke so richtige 6 mal ehrlich
sagen wir wissen was los ist mit pokemon
habe ich früher selber gespielt aber
pokémon go habe ich auch erst seit
gestern dann mit ein bisschen esther
kleber ankleben und dann wie bei den
anderen beiden auch die augen formen und
die ohren
pikachu bringen jetzt ist mein lieblings
packungen an der reihe jetzt pikachu ich
finds picacho sieht aus wie ella nämlich
auch so zwei zöpfe und rote bäckchen
also pikachu
picasso die pokémon sind fertig wenn
jetzt kann ich die cupcakes mit einer
creme bespritzen
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier eine
mascarpone sahne creme und da gibt es
auch bereits ein rezept auf seinem kanal
ein bisschen extrakt mit drin
und jetzt werde ich hier vorne starten
und jetzt könnt ihr die cupcake aufleger
draufsetzen und staates eben oder
schokolade ist geht es auch auf die
sahne creme
ja und so das war alles was er zu sagen
wollte die kurzgeschichte ja alles klar
na gut ich bin jetzt mittlerweile auch
mit den muffins fertig mit den cupcakes
und wie gesagt könnt ihr die capex jetzt
auch im kühlschrank lagern da die cup
cake auflege aus modelliert schokolade
sind kann man sie auch auf der sahne
creme gut liegen lassen wenn ihr sie
auch von dort macht müsste sie erst kurz
vor dem verzehr darauf legen dass sie
ansonsten davon dann auflösen kann durch
die sahne ja mal probieren die coole die
person drogen geburtstagsfeier ein
cooles gadget danach zwischen dem mann
tot auf jeden fall
ich würde jetzt gern ein probieren wenn
es war denke ich denn den prolog sondern
ich hätte gern kickern pokal
wenn es mit bayern anderem die namen ich
weiß von luft ist da eine viele andere
der grüne weste dieser song ja genau und
serie heißt keiner und nicht apple
sondern einfach so geradeaus natürlich
wieder komplett rot eingefärbt ja das
bin ich schön weil ich finde es passt
dann einfach nicht einfach so jetzt
drauf wie so ein burger es dann bitte
nicht so wildberger
er sollte so aus wie es sich denn jetzt
ja also ich hätte jetzt
das runter genommen und jetzt einfach in
den dingen reingebissen das thema
gegessen
übrigens wird wie schokolade schmeckt
wie schokoladen auflage also nicht sie
könnte in essen absolut geschminkten
super schmeckt süßer als schokolade muss
man dazu sagen wieso ein linksfuß und
autonomie und schokolade
was versteht sich prima ist denn anders
ließe mit gewissen wie zivilisierte
menschen mit messer und gabel bietet ja
würde ich auch sagen naja ist seinen
kaffee kaufen kann schöner pokémon
sammeln gehen ok mit samira was gestern
echt lustig habe ich euch das erzählen
weiß ganz mitgehen was sage ich mit dass
am iran gerade ein pokémon fang wollte
war bei uns im wohnzimmer und hab ich
den ball geschmissen und dann ist die
samira weg vom handy und guckt für mama
der ball verspringt realität und handy
vertauscht naja jedenfalls heute dass
wir nach machen wollt geht auf sadismus
und flott da stehen auch noch mal die
ganzen zutaten mengen und angaben
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen vielleicht macht ihr auch ein
paar andere pokémon gesichter wenn
jahren postet ein foto auf instagram
oder facebook und wir schauen uns das an
und lässt uns an
doch immer ganz hessen ist ausbilder
monaten in portugal zusammen er ist
bereits aus dem pokal zu werfen pokémon
ich treffe immer noch
ich habe angefangen